Is there ever an example of the rife machine creating insomnia?
KID the rife machine created insomnia, absolutely good. So anything could wake you up, right?
So if you are a real light sleeper, like I'm a super light sleeper, I was the one that first
woke up with all our kids I could hear them roll over and bad it seemed like. And the rife machine,
while I answer this, I'm going to mute everybody. We're getting some feedback. So when we
anything that is going to be a light in your room can increase your, it could decrease your ability
to stay sleepied. So that is, that is an issue with some people. If you cover it up, make sure
in some, so some of my fixes for that would be to try to keep it underneath your blanket.
Put the machine itself farther away from the bed, cover it up some way. We can get extension wires.
So right now I think the wires from the bulb to the machine, I don't know, maybe your six, eight feet
long. We've had a couple of people that we've got extensor extension wires from true rife for them
that went another 10 feet so that they could put the machine in the closet and close the closet door.
And they would hear less of the sound from that, because many times it's the sound.
So there, you're going to have to play with some ways to help decrease the any, whatever it is,
that's keeping you awake. And it's not the frequencies that are going to keep you awake, because there's,
there really isn't anything in your program, unless you have a brain cancer running brain frequencies,
then I wouldn't say that the frequencies would be the thing that would probably keep you awake.
I think it'd be the sound and the light that's probably keeping you awake. So those are the things
that I would play with. Okay, I appreciate that. This sound doesn't, I don't think,
well, it's hard to ever hear anything. I do cover up the plugin thing, forget what it's called,
you know, the better, I covered that light up, but I wasn't sure I should cover the rife machine,
because I didn't want it to overheat. Yeah, you don't want to cover the top where the air flow goes,
you don't want to cover that. I'd for sure cover the lights on the front of the machine up.
Again, I think I've told multiple of you that if I built the machine, I would not have lights
on the front of the machine. Okay, but yeah, try a few things and see if that makes a difference.
I will let you know that I'm not a light sleeper. You're a heavy sleeper, it still keeps you up.
Yeah, well, I don't know if it is, for sure. I just wanted to ask the question.
And that could be that I've been on taxa tier chemo. Yeah, I don't know if that does it,
but yeah, that's possible, too. You might want to Google that and see if that's what are the side effects
of that. Okay, thank you for your time and I so appreciate the video blog you're doing. Thank you.
You're back.